I got so much to learn
Caitlyn Jenner is heartbroken after
losing her mother Esther the Olympic
gold medalist revealing on Instagram her
mom died peacefully on Thursday she was
96 years old you know I always thought
that I got my courage and my
determination from my dad who landed on
Omaha Beach fought all the way through
World War II but you know what I'm
realizing now Mom I think I got all
those qualities from you
love you very much I'm so glad you're
here to
just share this with me
as Caitlin notes in the tribute her mom
was a few weeks shy of her 97th birthday
quote losing a mother is unique in the
sense that she is the only person that
loved me my entire life
Esther was grandmother to Caitlyn's six
children including Kylie and Kendall I
don't think I have ever been more
excited about life than I am right now
you always have doubts in your mind of
how that first impression is going to
work out following Caitlyn's
announcement in 2015 that she's
transgender Esther was there to support
her child's journey I love you love you
too I always did and I always I know I
know it's because I got this adorable
personality that's what it is it's the
adorable personality I like it better oh
good good okay Caitlyn ends her tribute
quote I will miss her tremendously love
you Mom
she was receiving that medal I never
thought it could ever be Minecraft
but I was wrong
[Music]